welcome to the day in the life of a
24-year-old that still lives with her
appearance often get ask why I don't
move out if I can afford to and the
truth is I am lazy and honestly your
Toronto prices is just cheaper to be
nicer to my mom so I made these protein
waffles for breakfast for everyone
they're so good they are 220 calories
for the whole thing and then I got ready
to bully my parents into buying things
that I want then I noticed that my mom
decided to copy my outfit how rude look
how cute this camera is I'm obsessed and
I have some pictures printed and on the
aquarium I'm just kidding we went
grocery shopping because they never know
to feed their allergy child then I have
to play with my new toy made some dinner
go my day if the idea of kids leaving
the home and moving far away and
effectively severing themselves from
their extended family is a modern and
mostly negative development then kids
staying at home and doing nothing and
contributing nothing and remaining in a
state of adolescent limbo is even more
modern and significantly worse